a lot of discussion on the David Pakman
show subreddit about the Democratic
primary including Hillary Clinton's
recent comments about Bernie Sanders
remember find the subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD i.t nearly
17,000 of our viewers and listeners
currently subscribed to the subreddit a
few interesting posts blue rice posted
will Hillary's attack on Bernie backfire
referring to Hillary Clinton saying
recently that Bernie Sanders that nobody
likes Bernie Sanders the post says I am
a rooting for Bernie or Warren to win
the nomination much like David Australia
desperately needs progressive leaders in
light of the bush fires and I think a
progressive president would help shift
the world's population to that kind of
thinking having said that I'm not
optimistic about bernier Warren's
chances but I want to see what effect
Hillary's attack on Bernie will have if
any my question is does Hillary
exemplify the mainstream politics that
the US seemed to reject in 2016 when not
considering the popular vote more than
Biden does if it continues to be
publicized could Hillary's attack paint
Bernie has more of an anti-establishment
choice and invigorate a different
section of Democratic voters or as
Bernie already seen as an
anti-establishment candidate amongst us
voters I believe Bernie is already very
clearly seen as an anti-establishment
candidate sometimes to a fault in the
sense that he is couched as this
outrageous radical who wants to tear
down all of the basic infrastructure
systems we have which isn't truly as
just a social democrat in the sort of
northern european sense but I do believe
that Hillary Clinton's attack could
backfire the thing is the backfire
there's there's two degrees the first is
could it backfire and get Bernie the
nomination question two is what would
happen if Bernie is the nominee - the
chances of removing Donald Trump and
fortunately for all of us we have new
polling about that which we will be
talking about a little bit later today
another post on the subreddit from a
user who goes by the name pedantically
Symantec says is david wrong about
calling Bernie's label of democratic
socialism inaccurate adding that there
does seem to be
overlapping semantics meaning if the
definition of social socialism is the
public ownership of the means of
production and the public is not
specifically stated as only the
government and the public can also mean
a collective of the public like
cooperatives of cooperatives and
capitalism is defined as the private
ownership and private can mean an
individual can own so as you can see
this is a very semantically intense
question I want to just answer it from
the top level which is as we've
addressed before if democratic socialism
now is being understood to mean social
democracy isn't it true that bernie is a
democratic socialist if what we mean by
democratic socialist is is just social
democrat I don't even think we need to
have that conversation the conversation
that I've had is that when socialism is
discussed in many circles the actual
definition is still used and so for
clarity I believe it makes more sense
for Bernie to say that he is running a
candidacy on social democracy not
democratic socialism I concede that over
time in society if we start using a
different word for something or if we
change the definition of a word these
are things we can determine and that may
be the case I don't believe we've gotten
to that point and I think that there is
only more confusion not less when Bernie
Sanders is called a Democratic Socialist
even though the policies are the
policies of social democracy people can
disagree about this that's my view as of
right now join the discussion at david
pakman.com slash read it